American history is neither cyclical or
progressive there is an attempt in our
desperate need to superimpose some order
into the random chaos of things to see
things as cyclical or to see things as
getting better but in fact human nature
is the only given here it's always the
same and it's got some very very
complicated things the fact that we
detect patterns is only because human
nature is so much the same our warlike
tendencies that means there is no hope
that wars will disappear until human
beings disappear that's what we'll do we
hope it won't be true but it's part of
the nature and it's going to take some
real evolutionary progress before that
isn't the case that people will fall in
love that they will be sexually
attracted to other people in
conveniently as well as conveniently
that will always be true that people
will some people will always crave a
kind of power over other people that
other people will accept power imposed
on them by others which is also true so
that we can recognize you know cycles in
American history we can see a
progressive movement but at the same
time what it is is just a series of
events into which it becomes the artist
or the historians or the combination of
both attempt to find some sort of
narrative form on that either through a
life or through a series of lives
through an event like a war the Civil
War a Second World War and to try to
find something meaningful I mean that's
all it is I think it was Tolstoy who
said that art is the transfer of emotion
I would say love from one person to the
other so let's just say emotion so it
does get half your audience terrified
about the word love that if it's the
transfer of emotion from one person to
another what is that about it's almost a
kind of courage it's almost a saying
look cézanne painted mouths and Victoire
his the mountain outside of his small
towns bedroom window and he painted it
over and over again as if to
say here here let us find some steady
place that we can know and to see its
luminosity to see it in different
seasons to understand it it was the
thing he returned to and again and again
and I sort of feel like I've made the
same film over and over again each one
asks the deceptively simple question who
are we who are those strange and
complicated people who like to call
themselves Americans what does an
investigation of the past tell us about
not only where we've been that's history
most people think but where we are and
where we're going because in point of
fact history the past is gone we're
never going to get it back and and those
who want to get it back the Buffs are
nostalgic and sentimental that doesn't
work but history is the set of questions
we in the present ask of the past and so
it is informed very much subtly or not
so subtly by what we fear what we love
what we wish for what we're anxious
about and therefore history
paradoxically is very much about now and
very much about the future you can't
have a future unless you know where
you've been you can't even have a
present unless you know the the sequence
of of movements that brought us to this
present